Here is a simple application
of the law of iterated
expectations.
We revisit the stick-breaking
example, which we have seen
sometime in the past.
So in this example, we start
with a stick that has a
certain length and which we
break at a point that's chosen
uniformly at random throughout
the length of the stick.
And we call the point at which
we cut the stick capital Y.
So the random variable Y has a
uniform distribution on the
interval from 0 to l,
and is described by
this particular PDF.
Then we take the piece of the
stick that's left and we break
it at a point that's chosen
uniformly over the length of
the stick that's left.
So the stick that was left has
a length Y, and the place at
which we cut it, X, is chosen
uniformly over that interval.
So in particular, X-- or
rather the conditional
distribution of X given Y--
is uniform on that interval.
So in this example, what is the
expected value of X if I
tell you the value of Y?
Well, given the value of Y,
the random variable X is
uniform on that range.
So the expected value is going
to be at the midpoint that is
equal to y over 2.
This is an equality
between numbers.
For any particular
number, little y,
we have this equality.
Now let us convert this concrete
equality between
numbers to a more abstract
equality
between random variables.
This object is a random variable
that takes this value
whenever capital
Y is little y.
So this is an object that takes
the value little y over
2 whenever the random variable
capital Y happens
to be little y.
But that's the same as
the random variable
capital Y over 2.
This is a random variable that
takes this value whenever
capital Y happens to be
the same as little y.
So the conditional
expectation--
the abstract conditional
expectation is a random
variable because its value is
determined by the random
variable capital Y, and it is
this particular function of
the random variable capital Y.
And now we can proceed and
calculate the expected value
of X using the law of iterated
expectations.
The law of iterated expectations
takes this form.
We have already calculated what
this random variable is.
It is the random variable that's
equal to Y over 2.
So this is the same as 1/2 the
expected value of Y. And since
Y is uniform in the range from
0 to l, the expected value of
Y is equal to l over 2,
which gives us an
answer of l over 4.
This is the same as the answer
that we got in the past where
we actually found it using the
total expectation theorem.
The calculations were exactly
the same as what went on here
except that here we carry out
the calculation in a more
abstract form.
And what is important to
appreciate from this example
is the distinction between
these two lines.
This is an equality between
numbers, which is true for any
specific little y.
Whereas this is an equality
between random variables.
This quantity is random and this
quantity is also random,
meaning that their values are
not known until the experiment
is carried out and the
specific value of
capital Y is realized.